après le conseil des ministres le
porte-parole du gouvernement le gabriel
attal a pris la parole alors aucune
annonce sur les potentiels restrictions
n'ont été fait le porte-parole a
néanmoins évoqué un retour à une vie
plus normale
peut être dès la mi-avril alors vous
vous en parliez ce matin avait lieu le
conseil de défense sanitaire il avait
pour rôle d'examiner les restrictions à
prendre dans les vingt départements
placés sous surveillance à savoir l'île
de france la somme la moselle ou encore
le var
des concertations qui ont eu lieu aussi
avec les élus locaux parfois en vision
visioconférence alors pour l'instant un
confinement les week-ends mis en place
comme dans les alpes-maritimes et à
dunkerque n'est pas systématiquement la
solution qui sera appliqué à tous ses
départements qui sont placés sous
surveillance il s'agit d'une option
d'autres scénarios où était discuté
parmi ces options
l exécutif a abordé la fermeture de
certains lieux certaines rues ou encore
baisser la jauge dans les commerces mais
en dans la capitale et bien c'est le
confinement les week-ends qui sera
peut-être privilégié en tout cas pour
l'instant on n'a aucune information
officielle mais président de la
république privilégie le cas par cas il
ne veut pas se précipiter puisqu'il sait
que ces décisions et bien elles seront
lourdes de conséquences sur le moral des
français
demain lors de la réunion
interministérielle le président abordera
également le sujet de la réouverture des
restaurants ou des salles de sport ou de
certains lieux culturels cinéma ou
encore théâtre et ce sera également
l'occasion d'évoquer le pass sanitaire
qui sera qui permettrait peut-être de
fréquenter certains lieux en tout cas il
faudra attendre encore demain pour en
savoir un peu plus sur les décisions qui
seront à dévoiler lors de la
traditionnelle conférence de presse du
gouvernement